Prof: Today we begin a
slightly different portion of
our course.
We'll be talking about the
periods in the history of music
beginning with the Middle Ages,
and I've pit--put--the names of
those periods that we will be
covering in our course up here
on the board.
Obviously: Medieval,
Renaissance,
Baroque, Classical,
Romantic, Impressionist,
Modernism.
We could even add to that
Post-Modernist now and probably
throw into that Popular Music in
a general way.
We're going to begin here with
Gregorian chant,
talking about the traditional
music of the Roman Catholic
Church.
We will not be promoting in
here the values of the Roman
Catholic Church any more than we
promoted the values of the
Jewish religion when we listened
to klezmer music or the Islamic
religion when we listened to the
Adhan or we will be promoting--
we will not,
in fact, be promoting the
Lutheran tradition when we deal
with Bach next time.
This ain't religion in this
course;
this is art.
So with that understood,
let's begin with an
introduction to medieval music
starting with Gregorian chant.
What is Gregorian chant?
Gregorian chant is the
monophonic, one-line music--
monophonic, one-line music of
the Roman Catholic Church as it
existed from the time of the
earliest church fathers up until
the time of the Council of
Trent.
The Council of Trent,
as you may know from your
history courses,
was a conclave held in the
northern Italian town of Trento,
Italy, from 1545 to 1563 at
which time they tried to combat
the effects of the Protestant
Reformation,
instituting reforms within the
church,
purifying the existing church
of Rome--
cleaning up the Catholic Church
in effect.
Among the things that got
purified were the art and the
music.
No more nudity was allowed in
art and any nudity that was
already there in religious art
was painted over.
Any sort of secular tombs were
taken out of the church.
Snappy rhythms in church music
were proscribed.
What music was sung henceforth
would be dictated by Rome.
No more new chant was composed.
So the composition of chant,
then, began all the way back
slightly--shortly after the
death of Christ and continued
into the sixteenth century.
What we call Gregorian chant
really went on for a period of
fifteen-hundred years.
From this, it is obvious then,
that although it takes its name
from Pope Gregory the First--
and you have his dates on the
board over there,
Gregory the Great--Gregorian
chant had almost nothing to do
with Gregory.
Gregory was a church
administrator,
a writer of sermons,
and an important theologian,
but it's only an historical
accident that he is associated
with this vast repertoire of
chant.
Gregory had an influential
biographer, John the Deacon,
who ascribed,
perhaps, more to Gregory than
he actually accomplished.
And, generally speaking,
in the Middle Ages there was
this tendency to ascribe to a
single or a couple of male
authority figures a lot more
than they actually did.
The point here is that
Gregorian chant was being
composed five hundred years
before Gregory set foot on this
earth and nearly a thousand
years after that.
What's the purpose of Gregorian
chant?
What did it do?
Well, it did two things.
One, it communicated the
message of the church.
It allowed for the transmission
of the word of God as they,
the faithful,
understood the word and
understood God.
And it transmitted the
theology, the message,
of the church.
Chant, then,
was a medium for the
broadcast--literally--the
broadcast of the word.
In a resonant acoustical
environment such as a stone or
stucco church,
one can project,
one can impel a text better if
you sing it rather than just
simply declaim it as usual.
I could say for example,
"Now let us read the
Epistle of the Blessed Apostle
Paul to the Romans,"
but the text projects better if
I sing it >
in that fashion.
It goes out better and it can
reverberate better.
Chant used for direct reading,
directly communicating a text,
was generally syllabic chant.
In syllabic chant each syllable
has just one note,
and in syllabic chant the
musical range tends to be rather
narrow.
The second purpose of chant:
Chant also allowed for a period
of reflection upon the subject
of the preceding reading.
A sermon, or a passage,
of scripture would be followed
by a reflective chant,
time for contemplation.
This music for reflection upon
a preceding religious theme was
generally melismatic.
Now a melismatic chant is one
in which there are many notes
for just one syllable of text,
and in melismatic chant,
the range tends to be a lot
broader.
It's more virtuosic.
So simple chanting for
readings, that's syllabic chant.
More complex chant for moments
of personal feeling and
reflection, that's melismatic
chant.
Let's take an example here.
I have my venerable Liber
Usualis up here,
and I'm going to sing the
Alleluia for Easter Sunday--at
least I'm going to try to sing
it.
And it's an example of a
melismatic chant and you'll
notice one syllable here,
"ah"
is conveyed by probably thirty
notes.
>
So that's a melismatic chant,
a moment of joyful celebration
associated with the resurrection
of Christ.
So that's what chant did,
and that's what it does today.
It is firstly a medium for the
projection of sacred text and
secondly a vehicle for spiritual
contemplation.
Where was chant sung?
Well, early on chant was sung
not so much in what we would
call public churches but more in
sequestered--
usually rural--monasteries,
religious communities
segregated by gender--
what, specifically,
we would call monasteries for
men and convents or nunneries
for women.
Remember Hamlet enjoining
Ophelia, "Get thee to a
nunnery."
The dominant monastic order for
both male and female in the
Middle Ages was the Benedictine
Order founded by Benedict of
Nursia near Rome about five
thirty Common Era,
the dates and names spelled out
on the board.
From Benedict,
the church received a code of
conduct prescribing how monks
and nuns should live the ideal
spiritual life while on this
earth.
Here is that book.
I once purchased this at the
Monastery of Saint John in
Collegeville,
Minnesota, about sixty miles
west of Minneapolis.
So this is the Rule of Saint
Benedict.
It told the clergy how to spend
the day.
It applied equally to male and
female communities.
The day was divided into
periods of work and periods of
worship--praying,
singing, chanting,
reading scripture.
They worked so as to feed
themselves and they prayed so as
to save their souls.
They were not so much
interested in good works for the
community.
They'd sort of withdrawn from
the community,
but in personal salvation,
saving their own souls,
perhaps the souls of others as
well.
The periods during which they
worshipped were called the
canonical hours.
The word "canon"
in Latin literally means
"rule."
A canon is a musical
composition that follows a
strict rule.
One voice has got to follow
another exactly in terms of
rhythm and pitch from beginning
to end,
but here we have something a
little bit different,
canonical hours following the
rule,
the canon, of Saint Benedict.
The hours usually involved
praying and reading scripture
and in singing.
And they started early in the
morning about four o'clock in
most houses at a canonical hour
called Matins.
Next they would go on to
celebrate Lauds about daybreak,
and so on around the hours,
ending with Vespers and
Compline.
And I might ask you here--we
actually have this service in
the Yale community,
broadly speaking.
It's not particularly
religiously oriented at all.
Have any of you gone to the
Compline service at Christ
Church across from the Yale
Bookstore?
As I say, it's not particularly
denominational in any way.
It's mostly in the dark.
It's very reflective.
Yes, Michael has.
I see some other people have as
well.
You might check that out Sunday
at ten o'clock in the evening.
It's just a lovely time for
peace and quiet and reflection,
and you can think about any god
that you wish in there and think
about--
and perhaps work through any
personal issues that you might
want to engage.
As to the mass of the day--we
usually think of this as the
principal service.
That, strictly speaking,
was not a canonical hour.
It was a special service that
happened, usually,
at around nine o'clock,
celebrated at the high altar of
the church.
So that's what the clergy did
in the Middle Ages by way of
worship: gathering at these
prescribed times to pray and to
sing.
And that's what the clergy
still does in Benedictine houses
around the world.
The most authentic of these
Benedictine houses is the one
that you see on the screen here
at Solesmes,
about one hundred fifteen miles
south of Paris.
Some years back I had the
pleasure of living there for ten
days to study Gregorian chant.
When you arrive,
the abbot comes out to greet
you.
He's attended on either side by
two acolytes,
and you go through a ceremony
of--in which he washes your
hands.
This washing of the hands was a
traditional--still is a
traditional gesture by the
Benedictines of hospitality,
and to some extent of humility.
You, the visitor,
are assigned to a cell.
Let's have the next slide,
Jacob, please.
There we go.
Okay, and I'll just signal
those.
All right.
So there we are with the next
slide.
You are assigned a room.
All right.
Let's go back to this.
You're assigned a room,
and this building has been
worked over, but that's where,
actually, I stayed--in that
building.
In that room you have a light
bulb, you have a desk,
you have a bed,
some fruit.
You have no radio.
You have no clock,
no television,
and certainly no cell phone!
How then do you get up to
attend the canonical hours
because in order to be in this
monastery you are required to
attend all of these canonical
hours?
What is it that wakes you up
then, would you imagine?
Hm?
Student:
>
Prof: Bells.
Nice and loud,
please.
Student: Bells.
Prof: Okay.
Thank you, Michael.
Bells.
Okay, the ringing of the bells.
They begin to regulate your
existence, for each of these
signal each of these canonical
hours.
Indeed we get our word
"clock"
from the medieval French word
"cloche,"
"bell,"
and our word--
the very word "hour"
comes from the Latin
"ora,"
"to pray,"
"orazio,"
or "prayer."
So we have the sense of praying
at regular times,
regular intervals around the
day.
At Solesmes the bells call you
to the church to hear these
canonical hours.
They call you to the refectory
to consume your meals.
And I submit that you really
haven't dined in this world
until you sit down and break
dark brown bread with eighty
hooded Benedictines speaking in
Latin.
if, when they are not speaking,
they are tapping particular
signals on the table.
And suddenly everybody will
rise, suddenly everybody will
bow,
and the visitor is sort of left
perplexed as to what is
transpiring but that's what goes
on.
As I have said,
this rule of Saint Benedict
formulated in the sixth century
prescribed this cycle of
canonical hours.
As the Middle Ages proceeded,
the cycle of hours was adopted
at cathedral churches even
though the strict rule for
communal living was not.
The daily timetable of worship
was kept, but the idea of eating
and sleeping together was
abandoned.
Cathedrals were much more urban
in their location.
They were not withdrawn.
They were in cities.
The clergy administered to the
spiritual and social needs of
the community.
The clergy was celibate,
de jure if not de
facto.
They lived in private homes,
not in a communal dormitory,
in houses that were situated
all around the cathedral.
Let's take a look at a typical
medieval cathedral,
and for this I'm going to
choose Chartres.
Now, it's not typical.
It's the most beautiful.
If you have one cathedral to go
to, I strongly--and I think I've
been to all--I know that I've
been to all the big ones in
France-- Romanesque .
What we saw before was gothic.
So here we see a group of
clerics centering around Bishop
Fulbertus there to the right.
This illumination dates from
right around the year 1020.
We'll return to Fulbertus and
hear one of his chants at the
end of our hour,
but for the moment,
let's pass on to the women on
the left there.
Notice that they are out to the
side.
They've been segregated.
Indeed they are physically
marginalized.
Women were to be silent in the
church according to the
scriptural dictum of Saint Paul:
"Mulier taceat in
ecclesia."
But, as we have seen,
there was ample opportunity for
spiritual contemplation and
creativity for women
specifically in the convents.
One spiritual leader within the
community of Benedictine
convents was Hildegard of
Bingen.
Hildegard lived in the twelfth
century.
She came from the area of
Bingen on the West Bank of the
Rhine River in Germany.
She grew up in a Benedictine
convent.
Here are the ruins of that
Benedictine convent.
And then she went on ultimately
to found her own convent,
and this is the--these are the
ruins--
or a seventeenth-century
drawing of that convent which is
now also in ruins.
Hildegard was a polymath.
She could do many things.
She wrote on church
administration,
on botany, on pharmacology,
on medicine and on music.
Indeed because of this
diversity we can I think fairly
say that the first
"Renaissance Man"
in actuality was a medieval
woman,
Hildegard of Bingen.
Popes and bishops sought her
advice--in part,
because she was a visionary.
She had visions associated with
the Christian story.
Hildegard also wrote Gregorian
chants.
So let's look at some slides of
Hildegard.
She was famous in her day.
Here we have a manuscript put
together in northern Italy about
twenty years after her death
with the representation of
Hildegard up there on the top
left.
The next slide takes us to a
blowup of this and we see the
representation of Hildegard
having a celestial vision.
That's why the wavy lines going
up from her head.
She's receiving the Holy Spirit.
She is copying down what she
perceives--not on a notebook
computer, but on a wax tablet
with a large stylus in her right
hand.
Her assistant--the one male
allowed in this community for
the sacraments--her assistant,
Volmar, peeks in,
astonished at what he is
seeing.
Another illustration of this
same sort,
the phantasmagorical Trinity
here with God the Father,
Christ the Warrior slaying the
devil that is now trampled under
his feet down below--
Hildegard is seeing all this as
we see from this illumination
here.
And a blowup of that again
shows us the wavy lines,
the descent of the Holy Spirit,
the writing on the wax tablet.
This time her assistant,
her favored assistant,
Ricarda, looks in again on this
particular scene.
Hildegard's music is
distinctive, and the texts that
she created for this music are
even more remarkable,
more than any religious poet
that I know--
and I have studied this to some
degree--
religious poet of the Middle
Ages that I know.
Her texts are the most
startling, her imagery the most
vivid, the most graphic,
indeed the most beautiful.
She talks of a saint in terms
of the "sweat of his
goodness shining like a balm on
his forehead,"
of the odor of the sanctity of
the Virgin Mary being "as
sweet as the scent of
honeysuckle and lilac."
Hildegard sees the blood of
Christ "streaming in the
heavens."
In her own musical creation,
with regard to them,
she styles herself simply a
breath--a "feather on the
breath of God."
What an interesting metaphor
but very appropriate for this
very modest individual.
She was but a "feather on
the breath of God"
with regard to her own personal
creations,
carrying out--going wherever
God would send her.
And you have on your CDs for
our course--
it's actually CD one,
track two--Hildegard's "O
Greenest Branch,"
and when you listen to this--
it's actually the basis of a
Listening Exercise that we will
get to--
when you listen to this,
you might be interested to know
that this was recorded right in
the base of Harkness Tower over
there.
It was recorded in Branford
Chapel.
And, although when you read the
liner notes,
it will say the Hildegard
Singers, the Hildegard Singers
were simply some female graduate
students,
ladies that were here
interested in singing early
music that--
for that particular recording
became what I labeled them,
the Hildegard Singers.
So that recording was done over
at Branford Chapel,
but let's listen to another one
from a group of four women from
New York City.
They're called Anonymous Four.
They put out wonderful
recordings.
And it's a good example of
melismatic chant,
again by Hildegard of Bingen.
Now you have the text up on the
board here.
I don't know if we can read it
but I'll read it off to you,
"O rubor sanguinis,"
"O redness of blood,"
"qui de excelso illo
fluxisti,"
"that flow down from
heaven,"
"quod divinitas
tetegit,"
"which divinity
touched,"
"Tu flos est,"
"You are the flower,"
"quod hyems de flatu
serpentis,"
which is "the wintry
breath of the servant--
serpent,"
in other words the devil,
"numquam lesit,"
"will never wound."
So that's the text.
Now let's listen to the music
of Hildegard of Bingen.
>
So what can we say about chant
by way of conclusion?
First of all,
of course, it is monophonic.
We hear only one line there,
monophonic texture.
Chant is monophonic.
Chant is also unaccompanied,
as you heard.
Chant has no meter,
no rhythm to it--no regular
rhythm at least.
It seems to flow as Hildegard
says, "like a feather on
the breath of God."
Now chant is enjoying something
of a rebirth at the moment,
something of a resurgence of
interest ever since the
appearance in nineteen six--
nineteen ninety-six of this CD
simply called "Chant."
It went platinum in its first
year, selling over a million
copies, outselling the Beatles
even for a time.
And it was succeeded by other
chant CDs, all produced,
appropriately enough,
by Angel Records.
We had "Chant II,"
"Chant III,"
"Beyond Chant,"
"Son of Chant."
There were Hildegard knockoffs.
We had "Mad About
Monks."
And if we had the original
Chant CD issued by the
Benedictine Monks of Santo
Domingo,
Spain, so, of course,
we have a knockoff now,
by the Benzedrine Monks of
Santa Monica,
California.
Okay.
Let's go on to the next slide,
which should be blank,
and I don't know what I did
with it but just last
month--here it is.
I don't have a good picture,
but just last month I went on
CNN online.
You know, you can see the
headlines there.
There was a headline:
"Move Over,
Madonna."
I think this was the other
Madonna.
"Move over, Madonna.
A CD of Gregorian chant by a
group of Cistercian is a
surprise cross-over bestseller
reaching the pop charts."
And you can actually buy this,
as I did, on Amazon or wherever
you want to buy it.
Why all this interest in chant?
Because it has much in common
with so-called "New
Age" music.
Chant is non-confrontational,
non-assertive.
It is somewhat laid back,
if you will,
as the mind and the spirit are
allowed to contemplate,
to form a divine communion,
perhaps.
Chant is the very opposite of
the music of Beethoven.
Beethoven tries to convince you
to feel a particular way about
every moment,
every measure,
in his music.
It is very much rhetorical
music.
Chant, on the other hand,
you can take on your own terms.
It is non-authoritarian.
It is non-assertive,
non-aggressive.
It floats unfettered.
And many of these same
characteristics are found in
"New Age"
music--hence the newfound
popularity of medieval chant.
Now let's turn our attention
away from chant,
away form monophonic music to
early polyphony,
multi-voice music,
music of the church of the
Middle Ages,
the polyphonic music.
Early polyphonic music for the
church was called organum.
It was first created in the
great urban gothic cathedrals of
France,
most particularly at Notre-Dame
of Paris,
so let's visit here our
well-known Notre-Dame with the
west façade and then some
of the famous laterally-added
flying buttresses around to the
south side there,
the southeast side.
It is likely not coincidental
that the high walls of this new
gothic style were being
created--
these courses of stone laid one
on top of the other--
at precisely the same time,
around twelve hundred,
that verticality was being
introduced to music.
What I mean is that all
cathedral organum was built
upward above a pre-existing
chant, above a pre-existing
Gregorian chant.
The composer took the chant and
placed it in the bottom voice
and then added other voices up
on top of it to form a
counterpoint against it.
It was the job of the tenor to
take the chant and to hold it
out in long notes.
That's why the tenor is called
what it is.
Originally, it comes from the
word Latin "teneo,"
"I hold"
or "tenir"
in modern French,
"to hold,"
the infinitive there.
So that we have this idea of
one voice,
the chant, holding on in the
long notes underneath--
was kind of the basis of the
music,
and then up above the composer
would create new polyphony.
What you see on the screen is
an example of this medieval
organum.
You can see we have four lines
in each brace,
in effect.
The one with "Vi"
has just one pitch.
You can see the big
illumination there,
"V,"
and then the pitch F out to the
right of it,
and it just sits there because
it just holds out the
>
"Vi"
as the music goes on for many,
many, many, many,
many, many seconds and finally
goes >
"de,"
holds that out,
and then finally down to the
bottom, >
"runt,"
as all of this other polyphony
goes on up above.
Let's listen to an example of
some of this medieval sound.
>
All right.
And we'll stop it there.
So it's very different,
but it's very complex at the
same time.
Again, a good example of
medieval organum,
medieval polyphony.
But let's turn our attention
now away from the music of the
Middle Ages in Paris to the
Renaissance and Rome--and
specifically to the Sistine
Chapel.
The Sistine Chapel was the most
famous of all churches in the
late fifteenth and early
sixteenth centuries,
the core of the Renaissance.
Why?
Because it was the private
chapel of the pope--not St.
Peter's, interestingly enough.
This is a shot of modern-day
St.
Peter's.
Let's go--there we go.
But this was,
during the Renaissance,
only beginning to be
constructed following the design
of who--of whom?
Which famous painter?
Michelangelo.
Yeah, Michelangelo was involved
in the design of St.
Peter's, but this was not in
existence at the time we're
under--discussing here,
big as--and impressive as it
may be.
So where the pope was actually
worshipping for the most part in
this period was not in St.
Peter's, but next door,
in effect, over in this
building in the Sistine Chapel.
And here, of course,
because it was his own place of
worship,
he could command the very
best--the best materials and the
best artists,
the best musicians.
Construction on the Sistine
Chapel began in 1477 during the
reign of Pope Sixtus IV,
hence the name Sistine Chapel,
Sixtus, Sistine.
Obviously, you get the
etymological connection there.
It's one hundred thirty-two
feet long and forty-five feet
wide.
The ceiling,
the famous ceiling of
Michelangelo,
is seventy feet off the floor.
Michelangelo painted,
as you know,
scenes from the Bible,
both the creation and the
expulsion.
He also painted scenes of the
sibyl prophets as written about
by Virgil in the Aeneid.
The side walls are covered with
frescoes of Botticelli,
Perugino, and Raphael.
Here is one by Raphael.
At the east end where the high
altar was situated there is the
famous Last Judgment scene by
Michelangelo himself,
painted somewhat later in the
1530s.
Just as the pope hired the best
painters,
so he engaged the finest
musicians--
the incomparable Josquin des
Prez, who will be the focus of
your Listening Exercise sixteen,
and Giovanni Pierluigi da
Palestrina.
You've probably may heard the
name Palestrina,
a prototypical Renaissance
composer.
They composed and they sang
both chant and polyphony.
They were members of the Papal
Chapel,
so a chapel in this period,
and even today,
can mean two things:
One, the physical building--
let's have another slide--the
physical building,
so that's one kind of chapel.
And two, the musical ensemble,
the choir that performs in this
building,
and the actual Papal Chapel--as
you can see here,
there is a loggia that
sticks out and this is where the
singers such as Josquin des Prez
and Giovanni Pierluigi da
Palestrina would stand when they
sang before the pope.
Now because this Papal Chapel
here sang without any
accompaniment of instruments
whatsoever,
even the organ,
that style of singing came to
be called a cappella,
literally a cappella
Sistina,
so unaccompanied singing means
without instruments.
If you are in an a capella
singing group here at Yale,
you are a descendant of this
tradition of singing without
instruments in the Sistine
Chapel.
That's what a cappella
means,
"in the chapel,"
but literally in Pope Sixtus's
chapel here,
singing without instruments.
In this case the Papal Chapel
performed in the Papal Chapel
standing in,
as mentioned,
the loggia that you see
there on the lower right side of
your screen.
Who were the members of the
Papal Chapel?
Well, they were all male
clerics.
We've said that chant was
segregated by gender.
There were also all-female
ensembles in this period,
but they were in convents.
But in monasteries,
cathedrals, and here in the
Papal Chapel,
then as today,
the ensembles were all-male.
But if they were all male,
who then sang the soprano when
polyphony was performed?
Well, at various times this was
done in one of three ways.
Males could sing in head voice,
which is called falsetto.
Any of the gentlemen in here
ever tried to sing falsetto?
>
It sounds pretty awful. Right?
Okay, but if I practiced that
it ain't bad.
I never practice it,
but if I practiced that--
and you can practice that just
like you can any other voice,
and it begins to sound better
and better and it can function
as a soprano line.
So that was option one.
Option two was to have
choirboys sing this upper part
and,
as this illustration shows,
this in many ways was a popular
medium of performance,
the old men and the young
choirboys.
But a third possibility that
came to be used in the Sistine
Chapel during the sixteenth
century was to assign the
soprano line to a castrato,
a male who had shown a
promising singing voice as a boy
and had therefore been subjected
to the process of castration to
maintain this high voice.
Now, there was some economic
advantage to the castrato
because one castrato could make
as much noise as three
falsettists or four choirboys.
The castrato had a high voice
but a very big body.
Now it has always seemed
profoundly ironic to me that the
one institution most fervently
in favor of castration of boys
to produce this high,
powerful voice was the papacy,
but that is an historical fact.
Indeed the popes continued to
engage and support castrati into
the early twentieth century.
We, in fact,
have a recording made in 1905
of the last castrato to sing in
the Papal Chapel,
Alessandro Moreschi.
His name is on the board.
I will now play a CD of this
voice.
It will sound very unpleasant
for two reasons.
One, the recording was made in
1905 so it's very old,
and it has all the surface
noise that those old recordings
have.
And two, Moreschi himself was
very old.
He was about seventy when this
recording was made,
and who has a good voice,
male or female--who has a good
voice when they are seventy?
So it doesn't present the
castrato at its best,
but at least it will give you
an idea of the sound of this
lost voice so we're going to
listen to a bit of castrato,
Alessandro Moreschi singing the
Bach/Gounod "Ave
Maria."
>
Okay.
Let's turn from that very old
recording to a modern recording
now.
It's a recording of a piece by
Palestrina written around 1590
for the Sistine Chapel here.
It is a Sanctus from a mass.
And for the parts of the
mass--the Kyrie,
the Gloria, etc.--see page
eighty-three of your textbook.
So it's a Sanctus of the mass.
And just as we have the Hebrew
prophet Isaiah--
and I think we can bring that
up now with the next slide--
on the ceiling of the Sistine
Chapel painted by Michelangelo--
so we have the voice of Isaiah
in this mass and in this music
for it is from Isaiah that the
text,
"Sanctus,
sanctus, sanctus,
Domine Deus Sabaoth"
comes,
"Holy, holy,
holy, Lord God Almighty."
Now this piece by Palestrina,
and I hope you--everybody got
the sheet there?
We've got the sheet of music.
You can--there's enough light,
I think, generally to see what
you have there.
It is written in four-voice
polyphony, but the aesthetic
impact of this polyphony is
pretty much the same as that of
chant.
Instead of one line of chant,
now we have four independent
lines, so we have polyphony.
Palestrina has taken a piece of
chant,
slightly--indeed what it was an
old hymn,
a monophonic hymn--slightly
animated the line through the
addition of simple rhythmic
values,
and placed it in four voices so
as to amplify the sense.
Four voices could do more to
amplify the sense of the chant.
Indeed this Sanctus has the
same relaxed,
non-aggressive,
unassertive,
yet very beautiful style of
chant itself,
even though there are now four
individual parts instead of one.
We've got polyphony instead of
monophony.
So you've got the music there.
Palestrina is overlaying,
sewing together here,
four short chant-like phrases,
and I've numbered them on the
sheet one through four.
Each of these phrases comes in,
in turn in each voice,
each voice imitating the
preceding voice,
so we've got imitative
counterpoint.
These passages of counterpoint
are called points of imitation.
This is what we get a lot of in
Renaissance music.
So we have four points of
imitation.
In point of fact,
it's--they sort of look like
four very short expositions in a
fugue.
But in this Sanctus,
in this imitative Sanctus of
Palestrina,
each exposition,
each of these four little
expositions,
has its own subject,
its own theme here rather than
one dominating the whole fugue.
Okay.
So here are the
>.
This is number one,
>
, and then number-- point
number two begins
>.
Number three across the page
>
and then finally
in that fashion.
So as we listen to this
recording now,
I have a question for you here.
Who is singing the soprano part?
Are these women singing this?
Are these choirboys singing
this?
Are these falsettists singing
Are these castrati singing this?
Let's listen.
>
So that imitative style,
relaxed, in terms of its
expressive content,
is very much the essence of the
a cappella style of
Renaissance vocal music,
and who was singing the soprano
part there,
of our four options?
Any thoughts about that?
Elizabeth, I can--
Student: Falsettos?
Prof: Falsettists, yeah.
That was a male falsettist
voice singing it--not women,
not choirboys,
and of course,
castrati are no longer an
option, so it was falsettists
there.
Yeah.
I'd like to end with one final
thing and that is--
enjoying myself today,
indulging myself,
dressing up,
getting ready for Halloween--
but the point of this,
in a way, is to try to give you
a sense of what this music,
and it's a very esoteric kind
of music,
is about--but really,
to do it in a classroom we
would have to take this whole
class and have to go to the
Cathedral of Chartres and we'd
have to sit there and we have to
be in front of a statue,
look at the beauty of that
statue.
We'd have to look at the
architecture all around us.
beautiful copes on the back of
the clergy.
We would have to see the
beautiful stained glass.
We would have to smell the
incense that is lighted.
I thought about doing that but
the fire marshal would probably
shut this down.
And what we can try to do
here--I think I have about a
minute left--
is go back to the Cathedral of
Chartres,
so let's--we have a slide here
and it's a slide,
once again, of Bishop Fulbertus.
He is the composer of the music
that you are about to hear,
and again it's sung by a female
group, however.
And as this music plays just
sit back and relax,
pretend you area having a
transcendental experience
yourself.
Sit back, relax,
and look at some of this
glorious stained glass and
architecture that has been in
this cathedral since the late
twelfth century.
>
So that's all for today.
Ite--ite in pacem.
Pax vobiscum.
Congregatio missa est.
I'll turn on the lights so we
don't kill ourselves .
>